but one effect of this technology is
we don't trust reality anymore we don't
we don't
trust even things that we see with our
own eyes because we know that they can
be manipulated like the emmys or even
like our politicians because it's not
just the emmys it was glitching out
it's nancy pelosi nancy pelosi was
giving an interview on abc news
and halfway through the interview it
seems like her brain just
melted and she didn't know what to do
and she kind of glitched out for a
second then they got the wires working
again
and she continued ten states as i said
on friday i started there early for
voting the
day that we lost ruth bader ginsburg but
to be clear you're not taking any arrows
out of your quiver you're not ruling
anything out
good morning sunday morning
the uh we have a responsibility
we take an oath to protect and defend
the constitution
of the united states you're going to
look at george stephanopoulos doing
the interview he's obviously a a cl a
clinton spokesman
he's a democrat flack and even he's
looking at he's like
what did i just witness what happened
to you huh she just kind of totally
glitches out for about 10 seconds in
there and then
gets back into it so we think okay i
can't trust what i see on video
i can't trust that these politicians are
at all with it
they're completely it's like they're
they're not even
alive it's like they're just we're
relying on
these people who have been in public
life now for 750 years
who seem to have a very tenuous grasp on
reality
so we can't trust them to make
persuasive arguments
more and more this is just a
bare-knuckle brawl for interests and
then you have the democratic nominee
for president who probably has the least
solid grasp on reality
just gave a speech about the coronavirus
in which he said that two-thirds of the
country was about to die
it's estimated that 200 million people
have died probably by the time i
finished this talk
but the complication of covert 19 like
lung scarring and heart damage
could become the next deniable
pre-existing condition
for over 6 million
americans 200 millions are going to die
before joe biden finishes speaking
this is two-thirds of the country i've
got a 67 chance of dying goodbye cruel
world
goodbye i thought that i had a 99.7
chance of survival
even if i got the virus but turns out
just a regular joe on the street
has a two-thirds chance of dying of
course that is not true joe biden was
off by
several numbers mathematics critical
thought economics never has been
the democrats strong suit obviously he's
not with it either
so you look around and you just say gosh
nobody
is he is even capable of making
arguments right now
that could allow us to use reason and
use prudence to govern ourselves as our
constitution
was intended i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure to check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you